les trois élèves musulmanes refusent de
quitter leur foulard islamique à
l'intérieur de l'établissement
d'affaires dufouleur s'est encore durcie
octobre 1989 à creil dans l'oise
trois jeunes filles sont exclus par leur
principal parce qu'elles portent le
foulard islamique dans l'ensemble de
leur collège
une interrogation émerge alors le port
du voile est il compatible avec l'école
laïque de la république française
pendant plusieurs semaines la question
vampirise le débat public mais aussi la
sphère médiatique intellectuels et
politiques s'affrontent sur le sujet
lionel jospin alors ministre de
l'éducation nationale a porté lui une
réponse plutôt ambigu s'ils se
produisent comme se sont produits des
cas de blocage c'est-à-dire d'enfants
qui vont à l'école notamment avec un
foulard sur la tête
je préconise que les directeurs
d'établissements et les enseignants
disent à ses enfants et à leurs parents
qu'ils ne doit pas venir à l'école
dans ces conditions si il y à blocage et
s'il ya refus jeudi alors l'école doit
accepter et accueillir ces enfants
un avis qui ne faisait pas vraiment
l'unanimité
dans l'opposition d'abord mais surtout
au sens même du parti de lionel jospin
pour exprimer leur désaccord de députés
socialistes s'affichait à l'assemblée
coiffée d'un foulard la position
division aussi au sein du gouvernement
si le premier ministre michel rocard
dénonce l exclusion des filles voilées
jean pierre chevènement le ministre de
la défense ne faisait aucune concession
à l'école laïque
il ne peut y avoir ni soutane et nikki
pas ni tchador parce que les collègues
c'est l'école de la liberté dans le
monde associatif les divergences
s'affiche aussi en novembre 1986
l'avocate gisèle halimi quittait sos
racisme selon elle la question du droit
des femmes n'était pas assez pris en
compte par l'association avis contrastés
aussi du côté des femmes musulmanes
si certaines dénoncé une atteinte à la
vie privée des collégiennes d'autres
s'opposait fermement au port du voile à
l'école à l'école - évidemment comme je
préférais que les faits les jeunes
filles musulmanes ne porte pas le voile
qu'elle ne se différencie pas comme ça
qu'elle n'affiche pas une telle
différence les avis de leurs camarades
face à ces désaccords le conseil d'état
sollicité par lionel jospin prend une
décision fin novembre 1989
tant qu'elle ne constitue pas un acte de
pression ou de prosélytisme
l'expression des convictions religieuses
ne peut être interdite dans les
établissements scolaires quinze ans plus
tard en 2004 une loi interdira
finalement les signes religieux
ostensibles à l'école
[Musique]